the Nexus he's trying to do it
[Applause]
guys League of Legends is a game that's
all about the snowball strong dedicated
macro play is often the key to success
but sometimes a call is made
sometimes a gauntlet is thrown and a
play happens that can end the game right
there and then that's right this week on
best of we're talking about the most
epic back doors and bass races in League
of Legends history I mean who doesn't
love a good race right all right guys
it's one thing for two teams to run it
down opposite lanes to each others Nexus
in some grand game of chicken it's
another entirely to sneak behind enemy
lines and steal the win here are the
best back doors in League of Legends and
that means the disengage for now they're
looking for a poppy by the time that
Nidalee is low that's true at number one
there's no the damage blocked up by
bronze it traded back at forge after
taking here
puffed and the reengage comes in its
order the dead heart is alive
Campos dead this - / 0 now Jen tobacco
unique going here going here think you
need to hide it back though go a nut
back toll he needs a run yeah run in a
back door in our there it does let's
just do it
they just got ping Tosh they still have
the man advantage Oh hot started like a
sneaky
[Applause]
trying to save the game as big takes up
the chairs going into will be knocking
down this turret into it here comes the
team that Keith goes down but here he
comes
ah [ __ ] now
GSF wants to break the wall right now if
they can get a kill or push in five
before naked theoretically in the game
which is stopping silent from being able
to teleporting right now the fear of the
five before because finally yeah gsm has
dyrus with the team
dyrus gets head up this might be the
time now he starts to teleport he goes
in dyrus is going to have to get out
with the team he leaves the slicing
Malstrom on crumbs goes through the
speed up on the ultimate Charlie will t
be unfit out there
the amazing gets hit Kiwi kids a little
too far here he's gonna have to try and
get himself out living a pillory on the
rest of the shots of fire science fart
kitty easily single-handedly win the
game by himself 54 54 of the clock but
necklace turq he has minions that's
gonna be out of the neck amazing kind of
basic he misses the shockwave for the
sonic wave I should say and he is the
tempest the [ __ ] made slow attack
not that oh my god he is going to be
able to hit it a few laughs
oh my
the inhibitors began the next
wins the game for take the time he had
172 helps by the time you got that last
hit on the nexus amazing needed only to
use his ultimate and he wouldn't stop
the push he's been in our no home guard
the QIO dominate slows him down a little
bit
dragging us up on my kills this sofa yep
several rooms bugging them reminding
them just go minutes go ahead buddy get
out the camp is okay it comes up to run
he was right here
the North American OCS patient trying to
look for trying to look for hot Souza's
come out come on leapfrog dog oh right
now ahead they're gonna try to initiate
this one beam just getting out of a
slippery situation there really and it
is going to be Han sir going down the
follow up and chase from the frost
Archer just too much and they pick one
up on the buy side five and three even
remember TSM loses something they always
have an idea of what to do next
even with Santorin on the other side is
that four base side they're going for
mid like we're not another basis on
going wild turtle is going on again
hitter with him and now fly quest prices
have played to stop the bat game and
again from the side Mindy bjergsen is
van caught a fight with Santorin key now
enters the back Ephraim Craig
going down yeah I'm [ __ ] with making
look yeah okay I met him this way
nice guys TSM down my quest bust through
the base for the win
TSM five men strong in the mid lane
it's inhibitor turret down as they have
nothing left defending the end hip 2d
will continue to push there in the
bottom side and gofox finally puts
themselves into a defensive position to
prevent TSM from taking anything else
so far it's one in hip for nothing
he's got the mini wave he's got one
it gets over so much of that game but
just like the black West game they lose
track of where they are in that split
bush on the side of Griffin they're
looking for a scissor play the pizza
what's J's tasted the bait head just
looking to try and win the game bot is
going to stop this fight but maybe they
don't want to now stop what's going to
be utilizing Georgia says okay have fun
of the team fight boys I'm in a win but
knows it's me that makes it hard now
Katy they're a man down in the fight but
Ruby should get taken out it's going to
be you cow that grabs that kill this
fight continues all the stuff watch try
and get the damage no one can actually
back in time look guys back doors are
hype but sometimes you don't have the
element of surprise on your side and
you've just got to get the whole team
together run it down mid right to the
enemy Nexus and send them a message you
can either try to stop us or you can try
to race us
no they don't they're actually gonna go
for this one the inventory goes down
what are the wolves go do the wolves
aren't recalling all the young buck is
there to defend the wolves are now up to
the ended time the denial on the
internet well you're not gonna fall
he's gonna fall very low will go down he
got his he no play no they complain a
wolf her toward Jupiter they've got the
first inhibitor they now on to the Nexus
turrets deny only going for it is well
the wolves are first they are the wolves
are gonna win it they throw down the
alternate the company go into the summer
split of the European LG keep I doing a
job there he's fed up of waiting he
hates that net Baron dance he just wants
to go shove Alain and they're actually
gonna try for a base race here Sunnah
just heading down straight to that
inhibitor tristana's such a good
late-game building destroyer here maybe
they're going demolition man is gonna
happen is listen we're gonna go for the
base race they are okay the red shirt
has gone down here we go Dignitas are
looking to kill off the inhibitor this
is going to be going these turrets are
gone on both sides and here we go on to
the Nexus for both sides crunk hitting
out of this per second toward the other
half but the other side is already
falling look at it down to the bottom of
the screen that turn
although equal they're both gonna be no
automatic who's gonna get it first
needed l+ dropping down who's it going
to be it's going to be [ __ ] take it
down the neck fit meanwhile as fields
going with the utility have a nice porn
Gatlin and it looks like they're gonna
base race top versus middle and face
race in it well and you just mentioned
the [ __ ] they don't even finish it's and
[ __ ] that said that Bush along the top
mana pushing along the top
oh my god that poor phone users that's
warning it tore it down that's gonna be
the second in in turn down I do not
believe they're gonna go for it it's
gonna be an epic race race clouds not
going in there they're gonna count 14 if
it's a certainty while at the top
they're actually losing our cloud line
are gonna win out this one the trueshot
barrage is gonna come across but it's
not gonna be enough to slow them down
inhibitor goes down that turret me was
going down they've realized to losing it
the relays are losing a fact it's not
gonna be enough Lake Edie they're losing
the Nexus turrets now you can see the
necklace
that's what can't they get a second here
comes echo echo back in time they're
gonna defending together wall up inside
this could be the curse to the side for
me to turn hitting on them as well to
two members have you been together still
punching meanwhile man and money to take
down the Nexus story in the bus in the
cloud nine wait that's a Gil there are
towards the natural story team part
again it take me I do not leave the
paint traces happen fantastic
performance cloud nine of just about
come back in time and it's 11:10 same on
beat cloud nine just like that became Oh
God
hoping laying in wait but then they need
to be quick to react here because the
rest of gambit are moving up towards the
parent this could be a back door they
could go for the in it
I don't recall instantly hey you don't
want which because you're gonna lose
this race you don't owe this is risky
this is super risky let's take stock of
what's up here bottom lane CLG pushing
any turrets down oh you mean it can be a
fast here yeah really really fast with
this Jack we see a recall from okay
CLG ago free on the bottom side but
they're already on the Nexus sorry who's
faster surely
coming through the meat Sal Extreme
Masters Cup final what the hell was that
very rarely do you get to catch these
kind of late-game shenanigans oh wait
look I can say it's got Brees go to the
plate to a debt on the side unicorns
their Russian is the double support play
in the base exile and samox are in the
face of spices while looking sleeping at
this nexus towers / spice we'll be able
to get down there as well
[Music]
look guys let's be real when it comes to
gambit plays like back doors and bass
races it's all about the highs and the
lows and that's great if you win but if
you made the wrong call and you're on
the nasty end of that w feels pretty bad
man I start racing well who needs that
plenty of attack damage these feel these
things pretty rapidly his OFI up as well
to even increase it sound when X is 2
right and what are you doing it's gonna
be a risk for their try for the defense
anyway Mooney is still pushing a time
they're trying to get it but that's a
Nexus turret down I wonder if I get the
win and they tie the series 1 was hooni
thinking there there was no way that was
gonna be even close in the base race ok
ambition and roll up roll are doing a
lot of damage and ambition who's gonna
throw his face into Griffin the know
cops gonna come down as he does get
himself out the fadeaway jump shot he's
oh my god by buff he is gonna get taken
down beador jaws ends there with the
lambs respite hey to manage to get the
mercurial scimitar out of ruler he knows
that he teleports into the Grimpen base
Genji I think they've just done it they
have done it they're gonna win this game
- sure
Derby Toby's got the flash honey do it
and he actually gets everyone running
back how many owners get again oh the
three minutes on Cape he doesn't kill
rule but that is so important ahead but
to get him out of the way to he dies and
gently win the game you have never seen
scenes like this in a competitive game
they were so close one more Auto would
have done it 80% here look at G to spin
and perks a running mint or permit this
putting up TSM TSM not gonna guys until
right now Gallego guys do we find those
Rudy rush back there so there they're
gonna force this now trick should
probably not go for a steal not get away
the kill that middle inhibitor turret is
dead the inhibitor is gone as well now
can they get a fight here in the 5 feet
through where they lose their base first
g2 are still pushing for the Nexus in
the bottom left corner
to fly for GQ tha back
let's go to particular Michigan go
low-tech 10-q eater
okay guys
take the winner for g2y Questor saying
five-man mid push go and it might be a
race here we'll see what happens grace
this the fly quest base race could be
going to be used here
what a face race black Wester behind
they roll down the gauntlet and they win
it by a sliver of HP like mistresses but
he's big thrower big outplay oh that was
force or a big throw even at the end and
have people teleported out of their bait
their Nexus that's being attacked yeah
to go attack the other one turret - all
being is 100% though okay well it's the
Brinks at home manages to get it now
there's gonna be the slow C's down there
using the tarkoff but they got two and a
half seconds to cut through the base and
it looks like it may just be enough time
but something to fight a start to break
out there looking for a chance to break
this one back Betsy's in the middle of
that everybody and he's not gonna get
taken down for while yet Sheriff won't
repeat himself
selphie pushing in Bruin gonna get down
it's traded target this wants to bring
it home I don't know if they can are you
who is gonna add the game partners wants
to bring it in
Oh
to be the hero the wrinkles Germany's
for so on
the rest of it so you can get into dirt
and I think he's there for the super
minions to coming in I say dr. Savage
just observe
folding down yeah but the play in the
stop to recall game in recklessness on
the heels right Mariko living artillery
he's gonna stop signing it has to one of
the big damage dealers don't go he's
gonna make it in that phase there
here comes cyanide as well on the end
they're focused on the guardian angel
lasagnas ten cyanide slip in as this
bowl well they've been able to get it
back K up from the guardian angel appeal
more heads
will this really it's be able start
trying to get in inhibitors are spawning
left and right the top one to still come
up but oMG also stopped their neck
destroyed ever seen a professional game
this close down at the stretch everyone
is expecting it's fnatic they're gonna
finish it so close hopefully not see all
right guys that's all we got for you
this week on best of now if you do want
more hype League of Legends content and
I mean who doesn't stay tuned because on
Saturday September 22nd we are dropping
the story of shocks now until then hit
that subscribe button and I will see you
next time thanks for watching if you
want more great content just like this
be sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]